"
♪ ♪
THE WOKE APOCALYPSE IS UPON US
AND IT IS FESTERING EVERYWHERE.
WE ARE GETTING OUR HANDS ON THE
MUG SHOT OF DISGRACED FORMER
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY OFFICIAL
SAM BRINTON.
THE NONBINARY NUCLEAR WASTE
EXPERT IS OUT OF A JOB AFTER
BEING ACCUSED OF STEALING
LUGGAGE IN TWO DIFFERENT
AIRPORTS.
BEFORE BEING CAUGHT RED HANDED,
HE WAS GETTING PRAISE FOR BEING
ONE OF THE FIRST OPENLY GENDER
FLUID PEOPLE TO WORK IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
REPUBLICANS NOW HOPE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS LEARNED A
LESSON ON WILL HIRES.
THEY ARE DEMANDING ANSWERS FROM
THE DOJ REQUESTING AN
INVESTIGATION INTO HOW SAM WAS
ABLE TO GET SECURITY CLEARANCES
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE DEMOCRATS' WOKE TRAUMA DOES
NOT END THERE.
IN WASHINGTON STATE, GOVERNOR
JAY ENSLEY HELD A SUMMIT THAT
INCLUDED A PRESENTATION CLAIMING
PHRASES SUCH AS OBJECTIVITY AND
INDIVIDUALISM ARE ROOTED IN
WHITE SUPREMACY CULTURE.
AND CAMBRIDGE DICTIONARY JUST
ADDED A NEW DEFINITION OF WOMAN
TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE.
THE DEFINITION DESCRIPTION EVEN
SWAPS OUT THE WORD SHE FOR THEY.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM IS.
I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE I'M ABOUT TO
GET INTO TROUBLE.
YOU KNOW?
LIKE WHO THEY, SHE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT AND LET'S START
WITH THIS GUY.
SAM BRINTON.
>> HE IS A CRIMINAL.
>> WHAT I WANT TO KNOW, A NUMBER
ONE IS WE DON'T KNOW IF HE HAS A
PRIOR RECORD.
WE KNOW IS AFTER HE WAS ARRESTED
AND MADE AN ADMISSION AS IT
RELATES TO LUGGAGE AN AIRPORT HE
KEPT HIS SECURITY CLEARANCE AND
HE KEPT HIS JOB AND HE IS
ARRESTED FOR ANOTHER FELONY.
SO THE QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW,
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY IS NOT
ANSWERING THE QUESTION AS TO HOW
THIS GUY WHO HAS A SECURITY
CLEARANCE BEEN ARRESTED ON TWO
FELONIES AND, YOU KNOW, IS
PRESUMED INNOCENT AND ALL OF
THAT.
HOW DOES HE MAINTAIN HIS
SECURITY CLEARANCE?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
THE PROCESS IT -- PROBLEMS A
POTENTIAL PERSONNEL I THINK HAS
SOME ANSWERING TO DO.
ONE I WAS THAT I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT A PREVIOUS RECORD.
IT SEEMS UNUSUAL THAT AT THIS
AGE, HE WOULD OFFICE AND START
STEALING LUGGAGE OFF OF THE
CARDS AT AIRPORTS.
AND I COULD -┘-DASH I'M WORKING
ON IT.
I READ ALL THOSE BOOKS WHEN I
WAS A KID.
THAT SEEMS UNUSUAL.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL THAT SOMEONE
MY LIE DURING THE VETTING
PROCESS IN ORDER TO GET AN
APPROVAL.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THERE COULD
HAVE BEEN IN THIS CASE
EXCITEMENT ABOUT HAVING THE
FIRST OF THIS AND THE FIRST OF
THAT AND THE FIRST DAY AND YOU
KNOW, WHEN HE GOT THE JOB, THERE
WAS A LOT OF CELEBRATION.
HE DID A LOT OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND
SO HE WANTED ATTENTION.
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT JOB.
ANY OF THESE JOBS WHERE YOU HAVE
A SECURITY CLEARANCE, IT IS
REALLY SERIOUS.
IF YOU SMOKE POT, YOU CAN'T GET
A SECURITY CLEARANCE.
YEAH.
EXACTLY.
SO I AM FOR DIVERSITY IN
WORKPLACE ON MERIT.
>> RIGHT.
>> I THINK AMERICA WANTS THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
NATIONAL SECURITY OR MIND YOU
ARE RAISING CHILDREN, TEACHING
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS AND ALSO,
THIS IS SO INTERESTING, WE DID
THIS TOPIC JUST THE OTHER DAY.
I READ MORE ABOUT THIS
ORGANIZATION CALLED DO NO HARM
MEDICINE.org.
IT IS SHOCKING WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN ACADEMIA BUT ALSO IN THE
HOSPITALS IN ORDER TO GET EVEN
DENTIST OFFICE, BECAUSE, IN
ORDER TO GET YOUR OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE, YOU HAVE TO
DO ALL THIS ANTIRACIST TRAINING
AND WITH THIS GROUP,
DONOHARMMEDICINE.ORG, THEY
BELIEVE EVERYONE NEEDS CARE.
THEIR CONCERN IS THIS TYPE OF
IDEOLOGY IS LEADING TO NEGATIVE
CARE FOR PEOPLE AND ENDANGERING
LIVES UNNECESSARILY.
SO I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO CHECK
THAT OUT.
THEY WOULD BE SHOCKED AT SOME OF
THE EXAMPLES.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HEARD ABOUT, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WAS READING AS WE CAME
INTO THIS WAS THAT WASHINGTON
GOVERNOR ENSLEY SAID -- ADVISED
HIS AGENCIES THAT CONCEPTS LIKE
OBJECTIVITY AND INDIVIDUALISM
ARE ROOTED IN WHITE SUPREMACY
AND SHOULD BE REJECTED IN FAVOR
OF INDIGENOUS RELATIONAL
PEDAGOGY.
I MEAN, DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
ON THAT?
>> WELL, ASK THE INDIANS IF THEY
THINK BEING OBJECTIVE IS A WHITE
THING OR ASK THE AFRICANS IF
THEY THINK INDIVIDUALISM IS
WHITE SUPREMACY.
I DON'T THINK JAY HAS EVER ASKED
ONE OF THEM.
THIS GUY SAMI KHAWJA STICKY
FINGERS, HE WAS NOT JUST ANY
TRANSGENDER.
HE WAS, LIKE, THE SEXUAL PIONEER
OF TRANSGENDER.
YOU GOOGLE HIM AND HE IS WEARING
LEATHER.
THERE'S A LEASH.
THERE'S A DUNGEON INVOLVED.
I WOULD NOT CALL IT DEVIANCY.
I WOULD NOT CALL IT PROFESSION.
LET'S JUST SAY HE IS SEXUALLY
ADVENTUROUS.
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE WORLD THAT
HE IS IN, YOU CAN BE BLACKMAILED
EASILY BLACKMAILED AND NOW IF
YOU HAVE A SECURITY CLEARANCE,
REMEMBER HOW JARED KUSHNER HAD A
HARD TIME GETTING HIS SECURITY
CLEARANCE?
JARED KUSHNER IS THAT WHAT IS
MOST -- DOES NOT DRINK, BUTTON
UP, YOU KNOW, VERY -- HE WAS
HAVING -- THIS GUY HAS A
SECURITY CLEARANCE, THAT IS HOW
INSANE THIS WAS.
SO THEY DID NOT AFFECT THE SKY
BUT THAT DOES NOT SHOCK ME
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT LET THE
AFRICANS THAT WERE CLINGING TO
THE PLANES IN KABUL.
YEAH, COME IN AND WHATEVER.
COULD BE AL QAEDA.
COULD BE ICES.
HOP ON BOARD.
WE WILL FLY YOU TO MICHIGAN.
WHAT ABOUT ALL THESE ILLEGALS?
THEY ARE NOT LETTING ANYBODY.
ANYBODY OVERSEAS.
THEY ARE NOT VETTING THESE GUYS.
NO, WHO ELSE ARE THEY LETTING
INPUTS, THAT IS WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT.
THAT IS THE POINT.
AND IF YOU CAN'T RUN THE
DEMONSTRATION PROPERLY, YOU
CAN'T RUN THE COUNTRY PROBABLY.
JONNI ASKED REGULAR NEW YORKERS,
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF A MAN?
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF A
WOMAN.
AND THESE ARE LIBERAL NEW
YORKERS AND EVEN LIBERAL NEW
YORKERS KNOW THIS IS, AS HE
WOULD SAY, JUDGE, HOGWASH.
>> THAT IS IT, BABY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE TRUTH IS, BRIAN, THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE GOT THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ABSOLUTELY INSISTENT ON,
INTO BEING GENDER FLUID.
AS THIS GUY IS.
HE IS NOT ONE OR THE OTHER.
HE IS NON-BINARY, GENDER FLUID.
I GUESS IT IS OKAY.
WE WILL ASK JUST, IN A MINUTE.
BUT YOU KNOW, THEY START
ADVERTISING FOR THE CIA, I AM --
GENDER FLUID INDIVIDUAL AND I'M
INTERSECTIONAL BIPOLAR AND WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE PILOTS IN THE
AIRLINES AS WELL, WHEN I THINK
BACK TO THE LAST YEAR, IT IS
LIKE MERIT DOES NOT MATTER
ANYMORE.
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS OBVIOUSLY
MERIT DID NOT MATTER IN HER
ELECTION.
THAT WAS POLITICAL IDENTITY AND
NOTHING ELSE.
THAT CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP
THIS COUNTRY.
>> I DON'T ENVY YOU HOSTING THIS
BLOCK.
HERE IS WHY.
BECAUSE NONE OF MAKES ANY SENSE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY AGREES
WITH THIS AND I WILL CHALLENGE
YOU, I THINK HE IS THE ONLY
PERSON THERE -- HE/SHE IS THE
ONLY PERSON THAT CAN BE
BLACKMAILED.
OKAY YOU CAN'T BLACKMAILED ME.
GOT HIM.
THERE'S NO WAY THEY CHECKED THIS
GUY OUT.
THEY DID CHECK IT OUT AND THEY
SHOULD PURSUE THIS.
LISTEN, AND ALL THE STUFF IS
POSTED.
YOU ARE THE GUY WHO SHOULD
HANDLE NUCLEAR WASTE.
HE WILL BE PERFECT.
ONLY 35.
NOT MUCH OF AN ENERGY BACKGROUND
AND INTEND TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIMES IN DIFFERENT OUTFITS.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
>> Jeanine: THIS GUY TAKES
SUITCASES.
>> HE GETS THE JOB OF THE
LIFETIME AND HE REWARDS HIMSELF
AND THEY PUT HIM THERE BY
STEALING LUGGAGE AND GETTING
ARRESTED AND IMPRISONED
EVERYONE.
I DON'T THINK, I THINK 99% OF
THE PEOPLE WATCHING US WHO HAVE
A TELEVISION THINK THIS IS CRAZY
TOWN AND OBJECTIVITY
INDIVIDUALISM IS NOT WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> ONE MORE POINT.
HE IS A POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
SO HE IS NOT PROTECTED BY THE
CAREER CIVIL SERVICE RULES.
YOU SERVE WITH THE PLEASURE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
YOU COULD BE FIRED FOR SAYING
HELLO TO THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WRONG WAY.
THE FACT THAT THEY DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY FIRE HIM IS AN
ISSUE.
>> Jeanine: THE QUESTION,
JESSICA, IS IF IT IS ALL ABOUT
WOKENESS OVERCONFIDENCE, PUTTING
AMERICA IN A TOUGH SITUATION AND
IF SENATORS ARE READY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND ASKING
FOR ANSWERS ON HOW THEY LET
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THEY ARE NOT
GETTING ANSWERS, AFTER A THIRD
LETTER, I MEAN, CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST HIDE AND
SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO TELL
YOU?
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
>> Jessica: I TOTALLY AGREE.
I SAW THAT THE SENATOR WAS
LEADING THE CHARGE ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
HAS NOT MENTIONED ONCE THAT THIS
IS A GENDER FLUID PERSON OR
TALKED ABOUT PRONOUNS.
THIS IS ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY
AND THAT IS WHERE THIS
CONVERSATION SHOULD BE AND THAT
IS WHERE IT SHOULD STAY.
IN TERMS OF JUST MAKING WOKENESS
APPOINTMENTS, I WOULD PUSH BACK,
YOU KNOW, HARDLY AGAINST THE
IDEA THAT KAMALA HARRIS AND THIS
PERSON ARE COMPARABLE IN ANY WAY
IN TERMS OF GETTING THEIR
POSITION AND I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT HER.
BUT THAT WOMAN IS QUALIFIED FOR
THIS JOB AND EVERYBODY WHO WINS
AN ELECTION OR TRANSFER OF
ELECTION IS PERFECT FOR A
POSITION, HAS CERTAIN ATTRIBUTES
AND IT DOES MATTER THAT SHE IS A
BLACK WOMAN, THE SAME WAY IT
MATTERED THAT MIKE PENCE WAS A
WHITE EVANGELICAL.
>> DO YOU THINK THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN, MIKE PENCE THE JOB?
>> NO, HIS RELIGION BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP 50 TIME -- AFTER
THE YOU KNOW WHAT TYPE NEEDED
SOME HELP WITH PEOPLE OF FAITH.
RIGHT?
WHO WERE NOT INTERESTED IN
VOTING FOR SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
STOP DIMINISHING KAMALA HARRIS.
>> YOU CAN SAY SHE IS GREAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO STOP.
>> OKAY.
SO DEL MAR AND BARACK OBAMA HAVE
BEEN TALKED ABOUT IS MAKING
PEOPLE FEEL BAD ABOUT WHEN THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
PRONOUNS OR JUST DON'T MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL BAD ABOUT THINGS
THAT ALSO ON THE FLIPSIDE OF
THAT, IT DOES NOT TAKE THAT MUCH
TO FIND OUT HOW SOMEBODY WANTS
TO BE ADDRESSED AND IF YOU DO
KNOW THAT DO NOT INTENTIONALLY
MAKE FUN OF THEM OR CHANGE THE
WAY THAT THEY LIVE FOR YOUR OWN
COMFORTABILITY.
LIKE YOU SAID, I'M NERVOUS TO
SAY X, Y, AND Z.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
>> THAT IS FINE.
I SAID NO ONE SHOULD BE MADE TO
FEEL BAD IF THEY ARE MAKING A
GENUINE EFFORT TO TREAT PEOPLE
WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY.
>> HOW ABOUT THIS?
I IDENTIFY AS A DOCTOR.
REFERRED TO ME AS DR. WATERS.
>> PhD OR MEDICAL, I'M PhD.
I'M NOT GOING TO --
[OVERLAPPING SPEAK